[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde je m'appelle
Grégoire Borchard j'ai 24 ans et j'ai
passé mon baccalauréat à l'école
européenne en 2016 dans la section
francophone je suis vraiment désolé de
pas pouvoir être là avec vous
aujourd'hui j'aurais aimé partager en
direct ce que j'ai à vous dire mais
j'espère que cette vidéo fera le taf
alors on commence moi ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que je suis arrivé à
l'école européenne qu'en 2014 avant ça
malgré le fait que je sois né en
Belgique j'ai effectué la majorité de ma
scolarité dans le système français en
Afrique au Congo et au Burkina Faso
notamment ma mère travaillait dans
l'humanitaire et mon père était posté en
délégation à l'étranger du coup durant
la majorité de mon enfance et de mon
adolescence mes cours ont été calqué sur
le système français mes professeurs à
l'époque ce sont contentés de suivre le
programme tel qu'il était enseigné aux
autres collégiens et aux autres lycéens
de France métropolitaine ça c'est ce qui
fait que en histoire au lycée français
Saint-Exupéry de Ouagadougou au Burkina
Faso bien installé au fond de ma classe
à 5000 km de Paris
et ben je me souviens avoir très
clairement passé en revue de manière
très approfondie l'histoire de la
construction des grandes cathédrales au
Moyen-Âge en Europe alors moi j'ai fini
par me rendre compte de l'intérêt d'en
apprendre plus sur les prouesses
architecturales des bâtisseurs de
Notre-Dame ou de la cathédrale
Saint-Pierre de Cologne
à vous que ça en jette quand même
maintenant est-ce que ça vous l'avez
déjà vu et ben ça c'est la grande
mosquée jingare de Tombouctou dont la
construction a été entamée au 14ème
siècle aujourd'hui elle est classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO et elle a
été pendant très longtemps un haut lieu
de la culture musulmane ouest africaine
parce qu'elle est située à Tombouctou
donc qui est une ville carrefour pour
les échanges reliant l'Afrique
subsaharienne à l'Afrique du Nord et du
coup reste du monde alors la plupart des
gens en Europe non entendu parler de
cette grande mosquée que au moment du
déclenchement des grandes actions
actions armées dans le nord du Mali dans
le courant des années 2010 je me
rappelle avoir été très choquée
personnellement quand à l'époque on
voyait des images à la télé de la
destruction des grands mausolées de la
mosquée de Tombouctou par le groupe
d'insurrections islamistes en sardines
ça c'était en 2012 mais hormis ses
évocations là c'est à peu près tout
assez paradoxalement pour nous qui
étions à l'école française de
Ouagadougou no manuels nos professeurs
sont restés silencieux sur la période de
construction de cette grande mosquée qui
pourtant un chef-d'oeuvre de
l'architecture soudano saélienne et puis
il faut savoir que cette mosquée elle se
trouvait qu'à 500 km à peine à vol
d'oiseau de notre salle de classe au
Mali qui est un pays voisin l'empire du
Mali lui dans lequel avait été
construite la grande mosquée de
Tombouctou en 1325 et ben il englobait à
son apogée de grande partie des
actuelles Mali mais aussi Guinée Sénégal
Gambie Mauritanie et aussi Burkina Faso
dans lequel moi et mes camarades nous
habitions alors pour moi ce silence de
nos professeurs et ben il était très
gênant à l'époque parce qu'il me
paraissait privé mes camarades de classe
burkinabè d'une partie essentielle
fondamentale de leur propre identité
alors que l'histoire de leur pays ou de
leur continent elle aurait été souvent
comptée à travers le prisme déformant
soit de l'expérience coloniale soit de
la guerre moderne
je pouvais rester tranquille j'étais
certain qu'il y avait de grandes femmes
de grands hommes des travailleurs des
révolutionnaires des écrivains des
voyageurs des inventeurs qui avaient pu
parcourir la terre sur laquelle j'étais
né et marquer de leur empreinte mon
histoire comme je suis passionné
d'histoire de politique et puis de
relations entre les peuples je me suis
un peu penché sur la question et je me
suis très vite rendu compte à travers
mes études et à travers les lectures que
j'ai pu faire que cette oubli ce biais
qui met l'histoire de l'Europe au cœur
de l'histoire du monde et relègue la
part africaine de notre histoire commune
aux banc juste de simples évocation ou
alors deux missions totales et ben ça
nous affectait pas que nous lycéens ou
collégien au lycée français
Saint-Exupéry de Ouagadougou alors il y
a un auteur en particulier qui lustre
très bien ce phénomène il s'appelle
horror French récemment je vous le mets
ici il a sorti un ouvrage qui s'appelle
burning blackness Africa africaine and
the making of the moon world
comme il le montre très bien dans son
ouvrage l'histoire des peuples d'Afrique
subsaharienne et leur contribution à
l'émergence de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la modernité et bien
longtemps restée inexploré voire
carrément volontairement occultée au
profit d'un récit
privilégiant l'image d'une ascension
fulgurante ou 15e siècle de l'Europe à
grand coup de découverte et
d'ingéniosité et c'est ce phénomènes qui
permet d'expliquer en partie pourquoi en
2007 encore le président français
Nicolas Sarkozy réunissant un parterre
de jeunes étudiants à l'université de
Dakar se permettait de dire que l'homme
africain n'était pas assez entrée dans
l'histoire du coup moi ce que j'aimerais
faire ici bah c'est revenir un petit peu
sur cette notion en vous racontant un
épisode de l'histoire du continent que
j'affectionne particulièrement et qui me
semble mettre en lumière en lien avec le
thème de la conférence d'aujourd'hui
whenworth collide le rôle essentiel
qu'on jouait les peuples et les nations
d'Afrique à travers leur rencontre avec
le reste du monde dans notre histoire
commune
qui a ordonné la construction de la
Grande Mosquée de Tombouctou c'est lui
c'est mansa Moussa il est arrivé à la
tête de l'empire malien en 1312 c'est
possible que vous connaissiez ce gars
parce qu'il y a pas mal de vidéos sur
Youtube qui sont récemment penchés sur
son cas souvent très souvent en
insistant sur sa richesse réelle ou
supposée et en effet les vastes
ressources en or et en esclave dont
disposait le monarque à l'époque et bien
il ferait aujourd'hui pas lire d'envie
la plupart de nos multimilliardaires
cependant moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
pas tellement de savoir si oui ou non
mansa Moussa était plus riche à l'époque
que Jeff Bezos aujourd'hui non ce qui
est intéressant avec lui avec son
histoire c'est de comprendre le ou les
effets qui a pu avoir sa décision en
1324 de parcourir presque
5600 km
à travers le désert du Sahara pour
rejoindre le Caire avec à sa suite
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes alors en 1324 mansa Moussa il
est parvenu à redresser la barre de son
empire qui avait connu un léger déclin
avant qu'il n'arrive à sa tête en un peu
plus de 10 ans mansa Moussa est parvenu
à faire du Mali non seulement le plus
grand empire d'Afrique mais aussi le
second plus grand empire du monde après
l'Empire mongole et certains auteurs qui
estiment que la production de richesse
au Mali et qui valait à cette époque là
à la moitié de la production de bien
total sur la planète le Mali était très
riche en coton en sel en ivoire mais
plus particulièrement de manière plus
importante était très riche en or et
puisqu'il faut savoir aussi c'est qu'à
travers ces conquêtes à travers son
expansion mansa Moussa a pu se
constituer de vastes réserves d'esclaves
qui en alimentant le commerce
transsaharien à travers le Sahara ont
fortement contribué à sa richesse et la
richesse de son empire
le problème pour moi samoussa c'est que
l'entièreté de la richesse du Mali
dépendait de ses relations avec les
royaumes marinides qui contrôlaient la
presque totalité du Maghreb à l'époque
en fait par leur position géostratégique
c'était eux les maîtres du commerce dans
la région et du coup les maîtres de la
destinée de l'Empire au-delà du Maghreb
et malgré sa richesse le Mali était donc
à peu près inconnu du reste du monde et
pour briser sa dépendance mansa Moussa a
entrepris en 1324 comme je le disais de
rejoindre La Mecque en effectuant ainsi
son Hadj qui est le pèlerinage
obligatoire pour tout musulman ce voyage
s'était l'occasion pour Manza Moussa en
fait de nouer des relations
diplomatiques avec le sultanat mamlouk
qui à l'époque contrôlait l'Egypte
déterminée à laisser une empreinte
durable dans les esprits vendre samoussa
il fait pas dans la demi-mesure l'enjeu
est taille il faut dire il suffit pas de
créer des relations commerciales il faut
aussi qu'ils puissent affirmer pendant
son voyage l'étendue de son pouvoir pour
pouvoir s'élever au rang des autres
souverains avec les il entend commercer
alors les estimations varient et il faut
savoir prendre ça avec des pincettes
mais à l'époque mansa Moussa est
accompagné de 60000 suivants en majorité
des soldats et des servants habillés de
très riches parure chacun des 12000
esclaves qui composaient en partie la
suite demande samoussa était chargé de
plus de 2 kg d'or les multiples
dromadaires et chevaux qui composaient
au sud aussi la suite de l'empereur
était quant à eux chargés de plusieurs
centaines de kilos du précieux métal
alors encore une fois ça dépend des
estimations mais les historiens
s'accordent à penser que la caravane de
l'empereur transportait aux alentours de
18 tonnes d'or pur contrairement à
Picsou man samoussa n'a pas conservé
tout cet or pour lui lors qu'il a amené
avec lui était destiné à être distribué
tout au long de la route et c'est ce qui
a été fait il y a eu tellement d'or de
déversés par l'empereur et sa suite en
Égypte que le prix du métal a chuté
entre 12 à 25%
l'économie de la région on est resté
déstabilisé pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années il y a presque 200 kg d'or pur
qui ont été donnés en cadeau au seul
souverain mamelook al Malika
la mise en scène de son pouvoir est ses
richesses par mansa Moussa ont très vite
porté leurs fruits le commerce avec
l'Egypte a augmenté significativement à
la suite de l'expédition et puis après
l'empereur de retour chez lui a pu
continuer à envoyer des émissaires
notamment jusqu'en Arabie pour
développer ses relations commerciales
par ailleurs en retournant au Mali mansa
Moussa il a pu ramener avec lui
plusieurs copies de textes religieux
islamiques importants à sa suite il y
avait aussi des descendants de la
famille du prophète Mahomet et des
spécialistes de théologie musulmane
durant son voyage il a aussi engagé
plusieurs architectes dont l'Andalou
abouit chacal saïli qui l'ont aidé
notamment à construire la grande mosquée
de Tombouctou ça a contribué à faire du
Mali et de Tombouctou une de ces villes
principales un grand centre de la
culture musulmane dans les siècles qui
ont suivi l'arrivée demande samoussa au
Caire et la débauche d'or et de richesse
dont il a fait preuve non pas eu que des
effets positifs comme l'estime
l'historien Michael Gomes la rencontre
de l'empereur avec le souverain mamlouk
anassyr au Caire n'a pas véritablement
permis amende samoussa de se positionner
en égal de celui-ci il faut dire qu'à
force de littéralement jeter leur par
les fenêtres Moussa a dû fortement
s'endetter pour financer le voyage du
retour au Mali et ça a pu contribuer
d'une certaine manière à ternir sa
réputation auprès des élites du Caire
reste cependant que en inondant le Caire
de sa bonté le souverain malien a très
fortement marqué les esprits en visitant
la ville 12 ans après le pèlerinage de
Mansa Moussa le penseur de Damas
allomari évoquait ainsi la persistance
du souvenir de l'arrivée de l'empereur
et de son fast dans l'esprit des
habitants de la ville la richesse du
Mali elle est rapidement devenue
légendaire tant dans le monde islamique
qu'au-delà des la fin des années 1320 il
y a des cartes qui circulent déjà à
travers l'Europe et qui font mention
d'un vaste empire très riche en or situé
au cœur du continent africain le large
donc d'esclaves qui composait la suite
demande samoussa à quant à lui contribué
à alimenter le mythe d'une inépuisable
ressource en main d'oeuvre corps véables
au sud du Sahara cette carte que vous
voyez elle date de 1375 vous la
connaissez peut-être elle est assez
connue en fait c'est l'Atlas catalan
c'est une des premières cartes qui tente
en son temps de faire une représentation
de l'ensemble du monde qui dépasse un
petit peu les doctrines religieuses
alors cette carte je vous la montre
parce qu'elle illustre vraiment
l'explosion à la fin du 14e siècle d'un
nouveau type de cartographie qui a pour
objectif principal de percer à jour les
mystères de la géographie africaine
comme vous pouvez le voir ici les voies
maritimes et la géographie des côtes
africaines ils sont représentés avec une
très grande précision cette Atlas
catalan c'est aussi un exemple très
parlant de la place que finit par
occuper la légende de Mansa dans
l'imaginaire européen à la fin du 14e
siècle comme vous voyez on y retrouve
une représentation de l'ampleur de
l'empereur situé au sud du Sahara il est
doté de tous les attributs du monarque
européen du Moyen-Âge avec sa son
sceptre son globe sa couronne par
ailleurs l'empereur man samoussa y est
décrit comme étant l'homme le plus riche
et le plus noble de ces contrées grâce à
l'abondance d'or extrait de ces terres
de manière intéressante on voit que la
carte montre le point le plus bas
atteint par l'aventurier mayorkin geomet
Ferrer lors de son expédition vers le
sud le long des côtes-ouest Africaines
entreprises en 1346 cette expédition
avait explicitement pour but d'atteindre
les sources de leur malien c'est la
première expédition européenne a tenté
de passer au-delà du 4 beaujador
aujourd'hui au Sahara Occidental
puisqu'à l'époque les courants
difficiles dans ces eaux rebutaient
toutes tentative d'exploration en
entreprenant son voyage vers Le Caire et
la Mecque l'empereur menthe samoussa a
donc littéralement contribué à mettre la
fric sur les cartes mais ce pour le
meilleur et pour le pire dans le siècle
qui suivit son voyage les navires
européens et notamment portugais
commencèrent leur exploration des côtes
senegambiennes deux siècles plus tard la
traite négrière transatlantique est en
plein essor elle coûtera la vie à des
millions d'Africains c'est avec ladite
traite négrière que commencera l'essor
économique fulgurant de l'Europe à
partir du 15e siècle s'ensuivrons comme
nous l'avons appris la sortie petit à
petit du Moyen-Âge l'installation de la
démocratie et des idées au des lumières
dans nos pays
demande samoussa quant à lui
n’apparaissait longtemps au
fragmentation politique ces successeurs
ont perdu peu à peu leur influence sur
ses multiples composantes la chute en
1591 de l’empire sangai qui avait
succédé à l'empire du Mali au tournant
du 15e siècle Marc quant à elle la fin
de l'unité dans la région sont suivis
une période de trouble intense et
violente qui contribue à notamment à
alimenter le commerce florissant en
esclave mené par les Européens
voilà donc pour conclure au contraire de
la plupart des thèses qui ont pu nous
être enseigner à l'école on remarque que
l'histoire des grandes explorations
maritimes des 14 et 15e siècle qui
marque la fin du Moyen-Âge et avec les
grandes découvertes l'entrée de l'Europe
dans la supposée modernité et elle a été
avant tout marquée par le désir
d'atteindre les sources de richesse en
or et en esclave de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
mansa Moussa en entreprenant son voyage
vers Le Caire a participé à mettre cette
partie du monde sur les cartes et à
attiser la convoitise des Européens du
coup voilà c'est tout pour moi j'espère
que ça vous a plu j'ai essayé de faire
de mon mieux dans les conditions qui ont
été les miennes je vous souhaite à tous
une un super Ted si vous reste des
conférences après et j'espère que vous
avez apprécié les conférences
précédentes bye